Speaker 1: We should be finding out relatively
soon whether Donald Trump is going to be indicted
for his role in allegedly trying to overturn the
presidential election results in Georgia back
in 2020. And the person who is saying that
the decision is coming soon is someone who
would know a thing or two about it. It's Fulton
County District Attorney Fani Willis, who is the
Georgia prosecutor, investigating whether Trump
broke election laws in the state by trying to
strong arm Brad Raffensperger and get him to find
the, quote, 11,780 votes. She told the Associated
Press that she expects to come to a decision
about whether to indict Trump by June 30th. Now,
that sounds very direct and it definitely sounds
like it's coming soon, especially because we're
in the middle of June now. But then we find out
there's a catch in that. That catch is that she
actually made the statement back in January. She
said, quote, I certainly think that in the first
half of the year, that decision will be made.
But who knows if between now and then things
have changed, if the timeline has been moved
back. What is promising, though, is that Willis
has been ramping up her investigation in recent
months. She's interviewed a few dozen people,
including Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger.
She was granted approval for a special grand jury,
but has held off on having witnesses testify
before the jury. Willis has also commented that
she would want to make the announcement after the
primary elections as to not give the appearance of
a conflict of interest or trying to influence the
race in any way. And those primary elections took
place a few weeks ago in Georgia. So now around
now seems like the right time to come out with
the announcement. Right. Are you going to indict
him or are you not? Especially because if she's
worried about this idea of election interference,
then, you know, you don't want to wait so long
as to run up against the November midterms.
You don't want to wait until right before
the general election either. So I'd imagine it's
probably coming soon to me. For what it's worth,
I think that Trump clearly broke the law on this.
I think it's a slam dunk case. If you look at the
Georgia election law, it says, quote, A person
commits the offense of criminal solicitation to
commit election fraud in the first degree when
with intent, then another person engaged in
conduct constituting a felony. Under this article,
he or she solicits requests, commands, importance
or otherwise, attempts to cause the other person
to engage in such conduct. And the punishment is
somewhere between one and three years in prison.
For what it's worth, and I'm no lawyer, but if
you take a look at the letter of the law there,
it certainly looks like Donald Trump committed
this crime and you at least have enough evidence
to go to an indictment and we'll let the jury
decide whether he is guilty. They also have audio
recordings of him. They can establish that there
was a well-planned, well coordinated effort to do
this. It certainly wasn't a one off thing by Trump
to like. He definitely has a pattern of this. And
there's witnesses like you. You definitely have
a solid case here. So my sense is that if they
decide not to indict, it's going to be more of a
political calculation than a criminal one. They
may just say, you know, we've never prosecuted
a former president. We don't want to go down that
road. So we're going to let him off the hook here.
And I hope that doesn't happen. I hope that he's
held accountable. Also, someone who thinks that
Trump is going to be indicted in this Georgia case
is Eric Holder, who was Obama's attorney general.
Let's take a look at him saying that he
suspects an indictment is going to come soon.
Speaker 2: I think, you know, you can look at
what Merrick Garland is going to do. I think my
primary, my first analysis would be what's going
to happen to him in Georgia? Well, you've got
him on tape saying, you know, find me 11,780.
That one is close to a layup. It seems to me.
I've always said the same thing about that. Why
don't they just go after that one moment. It's
on. Tape. You have the smoking gun. He's saying. I
mean, I remember when Rod Blagojevich was on tape.
Basically, it didn't work out too well for him.
No, I know. But but it was it was it was it was
pretty blatant, but it wasn't as bad as find me
11,000 votes. Yeah. Yeah. No, I think as I said,
I think that's close to a lay up. The D.A.
down there is going to be calling witnesses,
I understand, before a special grand jury. But
the interesting thing there is that that can
also be a specification and a federal charge
that could be brought in Washington, D.C.
When you're charging him with conspiracy to
defraud and conspiracy to obstruct, what happened
in Georgia can actually be part of a federal case
as well. So I think, you know, I was a federal
prosecutor doing political corruption cases when I
first came to the Justice Department for 12 years.
And you get a feel for these things after a while.
I get the feeling that I can see where this one is
going and a lot of high level people in the Trump
administration. I suspect the president himself,
people at the Justice Department, are all going
to find themselves on a little document that says
the United States versus fill in the blank.
Speaker 1: So there you have it. Eric Holder
suspecting that Donald Trump is going to be
indicted in this Georgia election fraud case.
And I just get the sense that if Trump is going
to have to face any consequences for his alleged
wrongdoings, it's going to be because of this
Georgia case like the other investigations. I
just don't see them going anywhere at
this point. The one out of New York,
for example, there just doesn't seem to be
the appetite to charge him. And we've had
resignations because it seems clear that they're
just not willing to go in that direction.
Merrick Garland and the Biden Justice Department,
I just don't know if they want to open up a
can of worms and start this tradition of
presidents prosecuting former presidents.
Trump probably could get charged for his alleged
financial crimes and his role in the insurrection
and the hush money payments that he had Michael
Cohen allegedly issue and that Cohen went to
jail for. But to me, this one just seems like
it has the highest chance of actually getting
an indictment, going to trial and getting a
conviction. So we'll see how it goes. We're going
to find out whether Trump will actually ever have
to face consequences for anything in his life.